okay so slightly different background
I'm still in Toronto I'm at the Toronto
International Film Festival right now
I've been seeing a lot of movies and I
finally have time to sit down and
actually talk about one of them so let's
talk about looper I had the privilege of
seeing looper at the premiere here in
Toronto Joseph gordon-levitt and Rian
Johnson introduced the film it was
really great to see them there it was
cool to see him walk out after Dark
Knight Rises this was actually my most
anticipated movie for the rest of the
year and I was so pumped to see it I
waited in line for a few hours all the
stars were there the theater was this
huge beautiful theater with like red
velvety curtains and everything it was
so cool it was awesome it was so so good
probably the most original movie I've
seen all year looper takes place in this
world where time travel has not yet been
invented however in the future it has
people send wanted criminals of people
who are to be executed back in time and
these loopers execute them since these
criminals didn't exist in this time they
erased them from existence it's totally
clean the criminals are dead they were
never even alive but whatever they were
going to do doesn't happen as a result
Joseph gordon-levitt plays one of these
loopers and one day Bruce Willis his
older self is zapped back right in front
of him and he doesn't know what to do
how do you kill yourself and solidify
the fact that your future self will die
at this date by your hands as Jeff
Daniel says in this movie that
time-travel crap is gonna fry your brain
and it does looper is a movie that is
really hard to relate to any other films
ever because it's so so original it has
such a cool plot but it's not just the
plot that's original it's the filmmaking
style this comes from the director of
brick which you guys may know was a
really great movie that I loved I did an
overlooked review of it if you haven't
got a chance to look it out I actually
gave it a a plus looper has such a
unique visual look to it it's absolutely
indescribable I literally cannot
describe the way this film is pieced
together because it's just so different
the use of transitions and an incredible
score to bolster each scene moving
forward one of the things that I was
worried about was will i buy the Joseph
gordon-levitt makeup thing will his
impression of Bruce Willis be accurate
will it be entertaining or will be
over-the-top and for like maybe like 2
seconds I was like honey yeah he's
wearing makeup and then it was just gone
it was instantly this guy was Bruce
Willis he had like all the looks down
like he would look
do that thing where first of all it's
kind of like squints one eye and holds
his lips tight and welcome to the potty
pal he's great in this movie he's so
good and he's really great in the action
scenes too he's really intense yes has
this great intensity to him as an actor
but one of the coolest things about this
movie was actually watching Gordon
Levitt and Willis's character interact
and seeing how the older and younger
self predicts what the other self is
going to do how they're able to
understand each other how they order the
same thing at restaurants it was just
really entertaining and made for some
really really fun dialogue I keep going
back to this but the thing that is so
great about looper is the way it's made
the direction the writing and the way
the film is pieced together the plots
pretty cool it's a little Terminator
esque but it's the way the film is made
that makes it unique that makes it
special and I really really enjoyed
looper the issues that I had at the film
are that the narrative can be a little
clumsy sometimes because with any time
travel movie it's like you have to
explain a lot of stuff you know a lot of
some narration that explains things with
a film this complicated and a plot so
intricate I can kind of understand why
it's just that some of that was a little
bit jumbled and a little murky at times
the film is exciting it's enthralling it
has a terrific ending definitely check
out looper when it comes out it was one
of the coolest experiences to be there
at the premiere I'm gonna have more
reviews for you guys coming very soon
I've now seen Dredd 3d The Place Beyond
The Pines Seven Psychopaths and today
I'm gonna try to see Cloud Atlas thanks
a lot for watching guys and I'll see you
very soon with more reviews and as
always if you like this and you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]